ernest becker talked about the
in his book denial of death about the
fear of death and being an important
motivator
in our life
as william james said death is the warm
at the core of the human condition
is it possible that this kind of
search for meaning
is uh
coupled
or can be seen from the perspective of
trying to escape the reality
the thought of one's own mortality
yeah becker and the terror management
theory that have come out of it there's
been some good work um
around sort of providing empirical
support for that claim um
some of the work not so good so so which
aspects do you find convincing can you
still man that case and then can you
argue against it
so what aspects i find convincing is
that human
being human finitude being finite
being inherently limited
is uh very problematic for us
[Laughter]
given the extensive use of the word
problematic i like that you use that
word to describe one's own mortality
it's problematic because people sort of
on twitter use the word problematic when
they disagree with somebody but this to
me seems to be the ultimate problematic
aspect of the human condition is that we
die and it ends i think i'm not
disagreeing with you but i'm trying to
i'm trying to get you to consider that
your mortality is not an event in the
future it's a state you're in right now
that's what i'm trying to get that's
what i'm trying to shift um
so your mortality is just a
we talk about something that causes
mortality fatal
yes but what we what we actually mean is
it's full of fate and i don't mean in
you know in the sense of things are
pre-written what i mean in is the sense
of
the universe doesn't care
about your personal narrative you can
just have met
the person that is going to be the love
of your life it's the culmination of
your whole
project for happiness and you step into
the street and a truck hits you and you
die
that's mortality mortality isn't just
some far-flung event it's that every
moment
we are subject
to fate in that way
so you can think of lots of little
deaths
you experience whenever
all the projects and the plans you make
come up against the fact that the
universe can just roll over them
the death
is the indifference of nature of the
universe to your to your existence and
so in that sense it is always here with
us
yeah but you're vulnerable in so many
ways other than just the ending of your
biological life
um because it's interesting if you rate
what people fear most death is not
number one they often put public
speaking as number one yeah because the
death of status
or reputation
can also be a profound loss for for
human beings you drive them into despair
so as the terror management folks would
say as ernest becker would say that
you know a self-report on a survey is
not an accurate way to capture what is
actually at the core of the motivation
of a human being sure that we could be
terrified of death and we from childhood
since we realized
the the absurdity of the fact that the
right ends we've learned to really
try to forget about it try to construct
illusions that um
that
allow us to escape momentarily or for
prolonged periods of time
the the realization that we die okay so
first i took it seriously but now i want
to say why there's some empirical work
that makes me want to reconsider so
terror management theory is you do
things like you give a people a list of
words to read and you and in those words
in that in those lists are words
associated with deaf cough and funeral
and then you see what happens to people
and generally they start to become more
rigid in their thinking they tend to
identify with their world view
they lose cognitive flexibility
that's if you present it to them in that
third person perspective but if you get
them to go in the first first person
perspective and imagine that they're
dying
and that the people that they care about
are there with them
they don't show
those responses in fact they show us an
increase in cognitive flexibility and
increase in openness see so i'm trying
to say
we might be putting the cart before the
horse it might not be death per se but
the kind of meaning that is present or
absent in depth that's the crucial thing
for us
by the way to push back i don't think
you took it seriously i don't think you
truly steel manned the case because uh
you're saying that death is always
present with us yes but
isn't there a case to be made that it is
one of the major motivators nietzsche
will to power freud wanting to have sex
with your mother uh all the different
explanations of what is truly motivating
us human beings isn't there a strong
case to be made that this death thing
is a really damn good
um if not anything a tool
to motivate the behavior of humans
i'm not saying that
the avoidance of death is not
significant for human beings but i'm
proposing to you
that
human beings have a capacity for
considering certain deaths meaningful
and certain deaths meaningless
and people and we have lots of evidence
that people are
are willing to sacrifice their
biological existence
for a death they consider meaningful are
you personally afraid of your death do
you think about it as a as somebody
who produces a lot of ideas records them
writes them down
is a deep thinker admired thinker and as
the years go on become more and more
admired
does does it scare you that the ride
ends
um no i mean you have to talk to me in
all my levels i'm a biological organism
so something's thrown at my head i'll
duck and things like that
but if you're asking me do
i long to live forever
no
in the buddhist tradition there are
practices that are designed to make you
aware of simultaneously the horror of
mortality and the horror of immortality
the thought of living forever
is actually horrific to me
are those the only two options
like um
when you're sitting with a loved one
or watching a movie you just really love
or a book you really love you don't want
it to end
you don't necessarily always flip it to
the other aspect
the the complete opposite of the thought
experiment what happens if the book
lasts forever
there's got to be a middle ground like
the snooze button sure you don't want to
sleep forever but maybe press the snooze
button and get an extra 15 minutes
so there's surely some kind of
balance that that fear
seems to be
a source of an intense appreciation of
the moment in part
i mean that's what the stoics talked
about sort of the to meditate on one's
mortality seems to be a nice wake-up
call to
that life is uh full of moments that are
beautiful and then you don't get an
infinite number of them
right and the stoic response was not the
project of trying to extend
the duration of your life but to deepen
those moments so they become as
satisfying as possible so that when
death comes it does not strike you as
any kind of calamity does that project
ring true for your own personal feelings
i think so do you think about your
mortality i used to i don't so much
anymore
um
part of it as i'm older and your
temporal horizon flips
somewhere in your 30s or 40s you don't
live from your birth you live towards
your death
that's such a beautiful phrase the
temporal horizon flips that's so true
that's so true
at what point is that
that the the point before which
the the world
of opportunity and possibility is
infinite before you yeah it's like peter
pan there's all these golden
possibilities and you fly around between
them yes very much
and then when it flips you start to look
for
a different model uh
the socratic the stoic model buddhism
has also influenced me which is more
about
wait
when i look at my desires
i seem to have two meta desires in
addition to satisfying a particular
desire
i want whatever satisfies my desire to
be real
and whatever is satisfying my desire to
not cause internal conflict but bring
something like peace of mind and so
i more and more move towards how can i
live such that those two meta desires
are a constant frame
within which i'm trying to satisfy my
specific desires
you